[Musica]
mike leigh e we are going to arnò law
and games
anais organi
iceberg no tu sei clip college student
che è un no frills kermesse news su
paranormal entity johnnie walker il 90
su guadagni i soldi questi partiamo
eccolo
c'è gesù cristo allora è perso i sensi
it che non me ne frega niente con lui
stai dicendo devo riprendere la gente
riprendo voglio godermi questa sana
avventura senza rotture di palle al
telefono c'è suo fallo smettere
bellissimo va bene partenza da 10 ok
grazie gesù avanti allora e
ragazzi basta basta basta parlare
bullonati pista bottiglia tra il filo
devo rimanere family friends rimane
finire ma non per qualcosa perché poi li
poi mi avrà detto il dottore che poi mi
più io ma devo stare calmo
porca [ __ ] che cazzo successo
è tanto tu sei al telefono non sei una
sega sono io mi pioli farti grazie
guarda che devi anche mi deve evocare i
fantasmi al telefono ma che cazzo riti
ragazzi è orribile ce l'avevo detto io
sono qua è quello mi parla al telefono e
tranquillo lui tanto mela pio nel culo
se locale guance eccolo ecco l'altro sta
camminando completamente a caso
sono michael jackson cosa diavolo è
guarda
ragazzi e ragazze ragazzi
ragazzi questo al telefono mi fa
guardare
potreste darmi una mano vi regalo un
telefono a testa se meno togliete di
mezzo perché va a cagà to write
no e se per te una porta
così la domanda al vado state sì ma io
tanto tanto schiatto io per l'amor di
dio non c'è problema perché mai dovresti
andare tu che sei al telefono possa
lanciare il telefono tu parli cioè io
sapete qual è la cosa divertente è che
in tutto questo voi potete stoppare il
video esattamente quando succede la cosa
per vedere che cosa è successo io no
perchè non non ho idea di cosa sia
successo perché so già tutto troppo
velocemente però credo che
porca [ __ ] la tua madre
mi dissocio mi 18
che cazzo è
a si è sollevato lettoni e tutto a posto
a posto pensavo peggio pensavo che ci
pensa qualcuno vi fosse venuto a
disturbare mentre stava facendo le cose
tutto accaduto che
ciao
[Applauso]
arrivederci
bella
io durante il black friday di amazon
comunque ragazzi non so no no no no no
no non si fa così non devi smetterla
santo di dio smettila quali problemi
devo avere io ogni volta che vado in un
posto abbandonato non lo so mi scusi
mi dà una mano a capire perché la roba
si si si muove da sola
queste stretching comunque state facendo
palestra ma è rivolta verso il davanti
semplicemente un cappuccio e il davanti
o dietro questo mi scusi
era il dietro capito
[Musica]
e fate una camomilla però chiara out ma
guarda io volentieri se questo non
tagliati fuori corri nonno occhi va bene
run corri fai gira ma prende proprio
ovunque questo cazzo di telefono
madonna ho sentito io me ne andrei di
qualunque indipendentemente da quello
che mi dice il tipo il telefono me ne
andrei forma dalle case proprio corali
corriamo quella porta non si apre mosso
cazzi miei
se se se se vado via
arrivederci
l
apostolo e già fatto tu così non devo
fare io posso giocare qualcuno no
l aiea ben friends on the phone l'one tu
sei di sponsor gratis mi scusi senta
allora io le tosco telefono che sto
tizio e parla lei mi da 250 euro e io
domani torno e ti do 300 euro fanno così
mi sto mi sono perso completare in un
corridoio sono riuscito a perdermi
perché viene anno si è creata un'altra
strada che prima non c'era ma qualcosa
esp fenomeni paranormali cos'è sto gioco
apri la porta
vabbè però se siete degli stronzi siete
dell'estro siete degli stronzi degli
stronzi non può fare questo non lo posso
fare ciò che ti sei anni basta basta è
ora di andare in pensione basta meno
male che erano un registro abito nella
mia cameretta da un po che sono i
genitori sarebbero spaventati tantissimo
con questo con questo jump scherma meno
male che dormo da solo come sono felice
io mi ero solo tu porca put a ogni
battello davanti miss march una strada
ma cosa tra l'altro tipo e telefono non
parla più e un'ora che non sa più
parlando il tipo al telefono è normale
tutto questo
non è normale tutto questo va bene
scusi
c'è un tubo che gocciola
anno e sangue porca [ __ ] un manoscritto
mai
ho fatto il classico errore negli horror
blog il classico errore del guarda te
l'ha poi guarda in album classico né ma
che pirla
beh è stato bello grazie sono proprio
divertito
un maron rubarmi o degli occhi grazie a
funziona ancora al telefono minchia
esiste
cioè una roba io potrei anche evitare di
prendere con gli occhi non mi serve
non è vero se rotta flashlight e tra
l'altro lui me l'ha detto con una
tranquillità come se vi si fosse rotto
un bicchiere è solo l'unico modo che ho
di vedere la flashlight grazie mille
raga mi serve una flashlight ve prego
banale to sorella morta ieri york
ma che
occorre corro corro corro
corro
ma che mag no vabbè
stamo a fa i giri è successo sento gente
che fa cose che succede
rissa con un santo iddio
ramelow storici da tre corri corri to
sorella korriku sorella
siete tutti
apre
ken jeong
bruttissimo
o la bibbia
ho una scelta
sì sì mi taglio gli occhi mi taglio gli
occhi certo
se tutto a posto zio
paranormale comunque ragazzi incredibile
cioè la e cinematograficamente parlando
è fantastico perché c'è un certe scene
pazzesche alla fine aveva una scelta se
fare una roba che non ho capito cosa
migliore o tagliarmi gli occhi mi sono
tagliato gli occhi però non c'e non c'e
neanche pensato tanto avrei fatto più
volentieri le orecchie perché a me non
avrei sentito quel tizio che comunque a
fine non mi è venuto a prendere signori
spero che mi sia piaciuto che sarà
paranormal entity gli schemi anche a
ragazzi è stato un commento sotto e non
ci vediamo come sempre al vostro video
bella ragazza
[Musica]
no